where humans are hard-wired to choose
mates with the highest possible value
our bio mall shoppers are all wearing a
number between one and six even though
they can't see their own numbers revel
and the others will pair off and try to
make the highest total number science
says that similar numbers will
automatically pair off with one another
six is with sixes threes with threes
[Applause]
online shopping you put a number I put a
number on your head no I'd like to
emphasize that these numbers were
randomly assigned so don't get bummed
out or impressed with yourself when you
find out that you're a 1 or 6 all right
when I say go you're a 10 Reds yeah so
you've got 30 seconds okay okay so try
to make the highest total possible okay
I'm gonna choose you and we're at we got
15 you got 15 seconds line up behind
here line up right here
having headband you should swear and
that's good stuff right there all right
you got a two and a three together here
so you guys came up with a five out of a
possible 12 that's not bad
here we got a four and a five that's a
nine now you took him you couldn't find
a five yeah it was getting down to the
last minute and you just had to grab the
highest number that we love it's just in
exercise that's the way works in the
market folks so a two and A three
but you guys going for something bigger
what was happening I was looking for
bigger and then you were like looking at
being going
no thank you okay oh that sounds so
sorry that's not right well you guys
five is better if I may just
mathematically speaking better to I was
looking for sixes and nobody was looking
at me nobody was looking at I wouldn't
be giving you the time of day at all oh
man I'm glad I'm married
yes dating stuff is tough so no rebel
yeah this gentleman here is a six you
found a six
I was decisive - I saw that six went for
it yeah just locked him down
locked him down yeah got me she grabbed
you pretty quick she was just like this
and that and she went enough and then
but BAM right just pulled in there
do you know what number you are one
rebel a one you're six
[Applause]
yeah I got a feeling you would have
taken her she was into six if she was
lower than a six with rebel I'm a winner
either way that is lovely they ended up
with who they were supposed to end up
more or less from an evolutionary
standpoint the sixes are with the other
sixes the ones are with the other ones
this experiment demonstrates the
phenomenon known as homogamy some
scientists think that happens because we
have an instinctual preference for an
equally desirable partner while others
believe we calculate our own mate value
through interactions with others and
then settle for the best mate we think
we can get
[Music]